The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: But the topic for
today is a big topic and an
interesting one.
So there's a lot to
say about it.
So I guess we're going to want
to get started on that, which
is MIT in World War II.
I asked you to read I believe
three pieces, the Hunter
Dupree article, four, right,
Hunter Dupree, Debbie Douglas
piece, "Science Analysts
Frontier," and
the cybernetics piece.
AUDIENCE: The Lily Kay too.
It was on the copy I have.
PROFESSOR: Was the Lily
Kay article on there?
AUDIENCE: There was no
Lily Kay on there.
PROFESSOR: Well, maybe
last year's syllabus.
I think we took that one
off for this year.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I read more than you
did this year.
Nyeh, nyeh, nyeh, nah.
PROFESSOR: But that's a
good one to add, as
well in some ways.
And the reason that I picked
those four is--
and actually, I think they're
quite interrelated.
And some people kind of
picked that up in
the response papers.
And I'll sort of underscore
that a little more.
In that one of them is about the
overall kind of national
science policy sorts of stuff.
That's the Dupree article.
One of them is about how those
changes affected life on
campus here on a day-to-day
basis.
The Wiener one is about how
those changes affected the
core content of what people were
doing on campus and the
actual kinds of science and
engineering that were going
on, because cybernetics
was very much a
product of that time.
And then "Science Analysts
Frontier" is a sort of outcome
of the end of the war,
looking forward.
And all of those things I think
have a big impact on the
MIT that you experience today
and the landscape of how
science is funded and organized
in this country that
you'll experience, probably
regardless of whether you go
into a research career or a
career in industry, certainly
if you go into a career
in research, how
technology gets generated.
So I just wanted to say a little
bit by way of review
and then go into some
other things.
And I have lots of pictures to
show, to give it a little bit
of texture.
So Hunter Dupree talks about
what he calls the Great
Instauration, which is actually
was allusion to Bacon.
And a few people comment on his
distinction between the
Baconian scientists who sort of
engaged in the affairs of
the world and the more
Cartesian model of a
scientist, who is sort of
isolated in the laboratory in
a purely intellectual space, and
that's an interesting way
to think about this whole thing,
and how these things
sort of formulated in the
years leading up to the
Second World War.
What is the generally accepted
start of the Second World War?
Anybody know?
Just date-wise?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Was it August 1939?
PROFESSOR: Close.
Within a month, September
1939.
AUDIENCE: The first
day of September.
PROFESSOR: What happens
in September 1939?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Nazi invasion.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Nazi invasion of Poland.
That's the sort of generally
accepted moment, although
there's the Spanish Civil War
before that and what not.
When does the US get
into the war?
AUDIENCE: December 7, 1941.
PROFESSOR: December 7, 1941,
Pearl Harbor, more than two
years later.
A very long period, where Europe
and most of Asia is at
war and the US is not only not
as the war-- it's not like
when we get into it, there are
a lot of people who really
don't want us too and think we
should stay out, Charles
Lindbergh among them.
And so this is this kind
of limbo period where--
and it's actually in a
way the same as in
the first world war.
The US is very late getting into
it and has a lot of time
to prepare.
If the US had gotten into the
war in September 1939, we
would have been a
lot of trouble.
There was nothing.
There was no military to
speak of in a sense.
Whereas by December 1941,
things had been
gearing up for a while.
And that's this period where
not only does Bush get
interested and involved, but
also the predecessor is--
there's this very interesting,
sort of curious committee
called the Scientific Aids to
Learning, that is done under
the National Academy of
Sciences, which includes
Vannevar Bush, James Bryant
Conant, who's is the president
of Harvard, a chemist, and also
Frank Jewett, who we've
mentioned before, who
is an MIT graduate.
He taught here.
He is then head of Bell Labs,
head of research for AT&T, and
actually president of the
National Academy of Sciences
in the 1930s.
And these guys all get together
on this sort of
abstract study about--
anybody know what
that refers to,
Scientific Aids to Learning?
It's a very modern
topic in a way.
How can we use new technology
to help education?
What are the new technologies
they're talking about?
LP records, 33 and
1/3 records--
does anybody know what
a record is?
LP records, 16 millimeter
film, to some degree 35
millimeter photography, these
are all the cutting edge media
technologies in 1939.
And there are people saying,
gee, there must be way to
improve education using
these things.
And it's interesting when
you think about--
we may have mentioned
this before.
We'll certainly mention
it later--
Vannevar Bush's great paper,
"As We May Think," where he
introduces this idea of the
memex, which is very much
credited as being a kind of
predecessor to the World Wide
Web, so right about
this time period.
So he's got exposure to these
sort of media film
technologies at the time.
And in the course of that
committee, these guys get
together and they think there's
really something happening.
The United States is generally
mobilizing.
Even though there's a lot of
political debate, people
really see that the US needs
to build up the military
during this period.
And it's not at all clear that
the scientific talent of the
country is going to be utilized
in the best way.
And a lot of people, and we
talked about this, during
World War I felt that it really
wasn't utilized in the
most effective way.
And Dupree talks about, there's
a lot of different
options for ways that you might
bring either scientists,
to use that term generally, or
people like you, to bear on
the war effort.
What might those ways be?
What are the different options
you might have?
Well, one option is to just
draft you all, send you into
the military, and then I've got
lots of smart MIT people
working in the army.
Especially the army in 1940,
you'd probably spent a lot of
time peeling potatoes.
You'd probably get handed a
rifle and told to run into the
machine gun fire.
I'm going to draft you and
rather than you being sent to
the front, I'm going to send
to the Watertown Arsenal to
make guns or to help engineer
the manufacture of guns.
OK, you go work for the
government, you work in a
government facility, and you
help with some important job.
That's not a bad way
to do it actually.
But you end up working
on things
that are already existing.
And so there are labs internal
to the government.
The Navy has them.
The Army has them.
Even the Army Air Force had
some stuff like that.
But they were generally seen as
not the most cutting edge.
And there's a lot of truth
to be said to that.
They were sort of concerned
with building weapons that
they had built for a long time,
not really very good at
dealing with things like
electronics or other new
things, and very, very hard for
them to think about stuff
that was outside the box.
If you were in the Navy, the
Navy had a great cadre of
people who knew how to build
warships because they built
best warships and that's
all they did.
But outside of building
warships, it was very hard to
think about what you might do.
Because that's what the Navy
did, was they built warships,
to some degree airplanes,
mostly warships and
submarines.
You could send all the
scientists and engineers into
industrial labs and have them
work in industry and close
down the school.
You could organize a separate
corps, where you say--
actually there are some things
like this today.
There's the Public
Health Service.
There's the NOAH corps, which
is the oceanographic corp.
These are sort of little
quasi-military organizations
that are peppered around
the government.
You could say let's have
a government--
well, there's a Peace Corps.
I'm sure you've heard of that.
You could have the War Corps.
And a lot of different options
there for organizing.
And these guys started to
become worried that they
didn't think that left to its
own devices, it was going to
go the right way.
And so Bush and his group,
particularly Bush in using his
political connections, gets them
took to create this thing
called the National Defense
Research Committee.
And he writes this famous memo
that Dupree talks about, in
June of 1940, which
happens to be--
anybody know that picture is?
What happens in June 1940?
AUDIENCE: Germans take France.
PROFESSOR: Right.
France falls to the Nazis.
So this is what, about
less than a year
after the war starts.
And here you have Hitler
walking down--
there's Hitler right there,
Albert Speer, by the way,
right there, touring Paris.
And that's a pretty shocking
image for the West to see.
And it was a time of
doom and gloom.
A time of really the sense that
if the US didn't get off
its rear end and start doing
things, bad things
were going to happen.
And you also have the
Battle of Britain.
And the Battle of Britain
refers, of course, the Nazi--
they were next going
to invade England.
But Hitler wouldn't do it until
Goering could give him
air superiority.
And so they started going
over and bombing and
preparing the ground.
And they never quite got air
superiority, because of the
Spitfires and the Hurricanes and
all this, not least of it
aided by radar.
And so in the spring of 1940,
into the summer of 1940, is
what they call the
Blitz in London.
I'm sure if you've
been to London,
you've seen that stuff.
Not only is there this sense
of military emergency, but
there's this sense that
a lot of the danger is
coming from the sky.
And we really don't know how to
shoot down airplanes and we
don't know how to combat
airplanes.
And there's this sense
of defense that is
not being taken up.
And so these guys from the
Scientific Aids to Learning,
and this memo that Bush writes,
particularly concerned
about anti-aircraft defenses--
and Harry Hopkins, who is the
chief of staff for the
president, basically puts this
memo in front of him.
And he writes across
it, OK, FDR.
And that's the letter.
And with that letter, in the
government world, if you have
that signature on your letter
you can pretty much do
anything you want.
It's literally like
a blank check.
And Bush goes around in the
summer of 1940 collecting all
these people to work
in this National
Defense Research Committee.
And they divided
up initially--
it's later called the OSRD.
And it's a little bit confusing
the way the
terminology works.
But they divided up into
different divisions.
There's a division for transport
and communication;
aircraft, submarines, and mine
defense; guns, projectiles,
and armor; and bombs, fuels,
gases, and chemistry.
And these tend to be things that
are not things that they
feel are being addressed
adequately through the services.
What's the one thing they
leave out, by the way?
They don't go near, they
don't touch it?
Aviation.
They feel that the NACA, which
Bush has then been chair of,
the predecessor to NASA
has aviation sewed up.
AUDIENCE: Is fire control
listed there?
PROFESSOR: Fire control is
under guns, projectiles,
armor, and materials.
And so what they do in a sense
is they grab onto all of the
technologies that don't fit
neatly into the services, the
military services.
And you'll see this again when
we talk about DARPA.
Because the Navy knows
how to build ships.
They're not going tell the
Navy how to build ships.
But the Navy doesn't know the
first thing about radar, and
they're not particularly good
at radio, and they certainly
don't think very much about
other sorts of things.
There's this great quote.
I don't know if it's in that
reading, from Bush, where he
says, there were those who
protested that the action of
setting up the NDRC
was an end run.
A grab by which a small company
of scientists and
engineers, acting outside
established channels, got hold
of the authority and money
for the program of
developing new weapons.
So they met a lot of resistance,
particularly from
the military itself, saying why
are you guys doing this?
And Bush says, that's in fact
exactly what it was.
It was an end run.
They went around all the
established people.
There are millions and millions
of dollars flowing
into Navy laboratories, flowing
into other things, but
building very traditional
weapons and things along the
lines that they didn't feel
were going to be really
thinking differently.
So they set this thing up.
It's outside the Army.
It's outside the Navy.
And you have no idea what a
bureaucracy is like until you
look at the Army or
the Navy in 1940.
These are organizations that
have existed for hundreds of
years practically, or at least
150 years at that point.
There was not a lot of rapid
change going on, except maybe
in the air arm in the Army.
And they bring these people on
who can actually understand,
who can manage the research and
pretty much write checks
with government money,
with a handshake.
This is not the NSF, where you
have to go through peer review
and you have to get your program
approved and all the
sort of things that a
lot of people here
on campus do today.
This is like, show up at
somebody's lab, ask them if
they'd like to be involved?
And the next thing they know,
they got a check for $250,000,
which in 1940 is a lot of
money for scientist.
And one of the things they
really get right early on is
this whole business about
electronics and what role
electronics could potentially
play in the war effort.
There's radar.
There's computing.
There's different kinds of
systems integration.
I'll talk more and I'll show
you some pictures about
proximity fuses and
fire control and
I'll mention radar.
And also of course, and Dupree
mentions this, there's this
uranium committee.
Which is another one of these
things that gee, it seems like
it has potential.
It's a bunch of pointy-headed
scientists telling us some
abstract thing that could be
the greatest ever, but
what do they know?
These are like Hungarian
physicists, who just have this
idea on a blackboard.
And this uranium committee
had sort of existed.
But the Army didn't
really own it.
The Navy didn't really own it.
And of course it belongs then,
it gets folded into the NDRC.
What does it become?
AUDIENCE: The Manhattan
Project.
PROFESSOR: The Manhattan
Then it actually branches
out of NDRC.
For a grant from the NSF.
And say I want to get $100,000,
how much do I need
to get from the NSF?
Anybody know what the
overhead rate is?
It's like-- and I'll get this
within 5% because I don't
follow it every year-- it's
like 63 and 1/2%.
So if I want to get a grant,
any faculty member you work
with that goes to the NSF and
needs $100,000 to do the work,
I have to get $163,500.
And that $63,500 from the top,
just goes right off the top
into MIT's bank account.
And the reason I ask if you've
heard about it, because a lot
of faculty complain about
it a lot because it
feels kind of painful.
And what does it do?
Theoretically, it goes to pay
for keeping the lights, on
keeping the heat on, somebody
to come in and sweep the lab
out at night, all the different
things, the
paperwork, that it takes to
actually run these grants.
And it is expensive
to do that.
And most faculty see it as a
big burden because gee, my
$63,500 which the NSF gave me,
suddenly gets taken as rent by
my landlord.
And what do I get in return?
All I do is get somebody who
comes in to sweep the floor
and it sounds like
a lot of money.
And Dupree really tells you
why that was so important.
And it was invented in this
month, pretty much.
And it was one of the most
critical ideas of getting all
this stuff to work so
impressively, which was--
MIT's total research budget in
1940, before this started, was
on the order of $300,000, the
entire research budget for the
entire Institute.
I wrote the number down here.
Well, in total MIT got from
the NDRC, $116 million.
$116 million, even in today's
world, is a lot of research.
And what does that mean?
It mostly means people and desks
and laboratories and all
that stuff.
If MIT had to pay for building
all those buildings and
building all those desks and
building all that heating and
all that infrastructure, it have
bankrupted the Institute
by the time it got
to $3 million.
But they added this overhead
charge on there so that any
time money came for research to
hire post-docs or research
assistants or technicians or
other people, it came with
this overhead.
That meant that the dollar
figure could grow infinitely
large, infinitely large.
And again, think about that
$300,000 to $116 million in
under five years.
We wish we saw that kind
of growth now.
And it was only able to happen
because they built into this
idea of the research contract,
this notion of indirect costs.
It was really a very fundamental
thing that we
still live with today.
That means that if I as a
faculty member went to DARPA
and I got $100 million
contract, MIT
could support it.
And they might have to build me
a building, which happens
all the time, you see these
buildings around here.
But they could actually do it.
The other thing about it was all
of the research contracts,
the military, the only thing
they knew how to do up until
then was to buy stuff.
It's called procurement.
It's still something
they do a lot of.
So if I wanted to do an
experimental radar set, the
only way I had to do it was to
come to MIT and go, we'd like
to buy 10 radar sets.
And we probably won't even use
them and they may not even
work, but at least we'll have
a contract that has a
procurement.
And what they invented during
this period also with this R&D
contract, where MIT doesn't
deliver anything other than
promising to put out its best
effort to do the research and
hopefully publish some
papers on it.
That was also a pretty
revolutionary
idea in that point.
Until that point, there
was no way for the
government to do that.
So here's what Dupree
says about it.
It's a nice little sentence
that captures it all.
The contract was the device
by which universities and
industrial research labs were
preserved as institutions,
even while their social role
was radically changed.
I mean this was very much the
vision that people like Bush
and Conant had, was we want to
keep MIT for what it is, keep
it as the character
that it has.
Obviously, it changed during
the war in some basic ways.
But it didn't change permanently
in some sense.
Where there's a free flow
of ideas, there's an
open flow of ideas.
But I haven't addressed all
these other kinds of problems.
Without becoming part of the
Army, or without it becoming
part of the Navy, or having
just everybody drafted and
closing the place down
for five years.
So the NDRC is created
in June of 1940.
It gets up and running.
It starts to issue its first
contracts in September,
October of 1940.
I'll talk about the radiation
lab in a couple minutes when I
show the slides.
Well, it's worth knowing that
they get started under the
NDRC in October, I
believe, of 1940.
They deliver their first
radar set in March of
the following year.
So think about the turnaround
there, to take a completely
new technology and to deliver
something the military can use
in the field in four months.
It was a pretty remarkable
turn-around.
And in fact, some people in
their response papers
mentioned the intensity of the
environment that sort of
developed around here
during that period.
And commenting, a couple people,
that it was hard to
imagine it was any more intense
than it is today.
Although it probably was.
And one thing that wasn't
really captured in the
readings is why it
was so intense?
What was it that was driving
people to work such long hours
and put such incredible
time in?
Again, most of the people doing
this work are people
just like you.
They're either students or just
recent graduates who are
occupying these labs.
Especially for the men, what
happens to all your friends?
AUDIENCE: Going and
getting drafted.
PROFESSOR: Well, what are
all your friends doing?
AUDIENCE: Getting drafted.
PROFESSOR: Either getting
drafted or signing up.
It's not that the people who
are working in the labs are
trying to avoid getting
drafted.
That's more of a product
of later wars.
They're exempted from the draft
because they're doing
critical work.
And there's a lot of social
pressure about not shirking
your service.
So it can be seen as a kind of
embarrassment to be exempted
from the draft to do
laboratory work.
It's a sort of cushy
assignment.
It's the sort of thing that
people like Dick Cheney and
George Bush were criticized
for during
presidential campaigns.
All your friends are going off
to war and you're staying home
in Cambridge, working at MIT.
A lot of I think the motivation
for people was they
really wanted to prove they were
doing something important
and making a contribution to
the war effort and not just
avoiding the draft.
Because they were exempted
from the draft.
And that they really were
serving their country in the
same kind of way.
This was not the Vietnam War,
which was very contentious
about who went and who
didn't go and who
wanted to get drafted.
This was where the entire
country literally mobilized.
And everybody's job, everybody's
home life,
everybody moved around.
And it really fundamentally
changed the
country for that period.
So you have this environment
inside the laboratories which
is very different.
So a couple of statistics, as I
mentioned MIT was the single
largest recipient of OSRD
already funds, I think by a
factor of two or three, $116
million over five years.
Again, that's a lot of money in
today's world, much less in
1940 dollars, where the
total budget was
$300,000 before then.
There were about 2,300 contracts
overall in the OSRD,
totaling $500 million.
So MIT got more than 20%
of the total funds.
It was a bit of an inside
job, no doubt about it.
The Radiation Laboratory by
1942, again it was only
founded in the end of 1940, so
within a year it was as large
as the rest of MIT
all together.
And it was of course,
right there.
The overhead started
out as 30% and got
reduced down to 10%--
again today it's 63 and 1/2%--
because they didn't want to be
seen as raking off all this
cash that came in.
And again, there was a
lot of resistance.
There's a great quote by Harold
Bowen, who was the head
of the Naval Research
Laboratory.
He was an MIT graduate.
He said--
he's coming from within
the Navy--
those of us who had been working
in applied science for
years cannot be blamed for not
always enthusiastically
endorsing all the efforts of
the Johnny-come-latelys who
inevitably steam into
Washington at the
beginning of the war.
So that was how they viewed
Vannevar Bush and all these
scientists, was they
were coming in.
We've been working on radar.
In fact, they did.
The Naval Research Lab really
invented radar.
And here comes Vannevar Bush,
saying we're going to do it
all at MIT.
And in a certain way, taking
it away from the Naval
Research Lab.
Very contentious stuff, lots
of power politics going on.
Also with AT&T. I'll
talk about that a
little bit in a minute.
Some of the other big
benefactors, and I mention
this because these places all
still exist and may be places
you'd come across, the
Jet Propulsion
Laboratory at Caltech--
anybody ever heard
of that place?
Founded right during
this period.
What do they do now?
AUDIENCE: Stuff for NASA.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
part of NASA.
They do a lot of deep
space probes.
They did the Mars Rovers
that you've read about.
They do essentially nothing
with jet propulsion.
But they were founded, under the
direction of Theodore von
Karman, to do rocket
research basically.
There's a whole new institution
out there created
right about the same time,
by the same thing.
The Applied Physics Lab
at Johns Hopkins.
Anybody ever hear of that lab?
Also a big government lab,
associated with the
university.
They do all kinds of interesting
secret stuff.
They do submarine tracking and
they do a lot of space design
and they build satellites.
And in fact, the former
head of NASA, Mike
Griffin came out of there.
And they were founded in the
same period to develop the
proximity fuse, which was
a little radar device.
It was built into an
artillery shell.
It was designed to explode when
it came near an airplane.
So these are all places
that still exist.
A lot of these big government
or quasi-government research
labs exist.
Let me maybe turn
to the slides.
Any questions on any of that?
I have a few more numbers
about the Rad Lab radar.
AUDIENCE: I mean one of the
things that comes out in the
article by Debbie Douglas is
that the significance of the
microwave research here at MIT
was it that allowed people to
make radar units smaller.
So what had existed before?
You mentioned the Navy.
PROFESSOR: I think I have
pictures of that.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
PROFESSOR: So here's
one example.
This will become relevant when
we talk about Apollo actually.
Again, one of the big concerns
was about gunfire control.
And this is a device--
I may have mentioned
this before.
Did I show this picture
before so far?
I actually have two of these
things in my office.
I bought them on eBay for about
$25, still brand new in
the box from 1945, when there
were manufactured.
And this is a gun site for a
guy, an anti-aircraft gunner,
aboard a Naval ship.
And what it does is it's got
two gyroscopes in it.
And it has a little mirror and
it automatically calculates
the lead for the gunner.
So if there's an airplane coming
in and you've got to
lead it by some amount in order
to fire ahead of it,
because it takes time for the
bullets to get there, and it
can be very hard to train people
to do that, that's how
you shoot skeet and stuff.
And what this thing does, is it
just says, if you just put
the cross-hairs in your site,
on the actual airplane, it
will automatically calculate
the lead and sort of force
your hands to lead the gun.
And this was built by, not only
by Charles Stark Draper
in the Instrumentation Lab here,
but also by Bob Siemens,
who was one of his students,
who then became second in
command at NASA during
the Apollo program.
We'll talk about that.
And was one of their first
forays into gyroscopes, which
then became really important
during the Cold War and later.
I keep pushing the wrong
side of the mouse.
And this is actually
how it worked.
So you can see they can just
see the site and it sort of
forces the gunner, if he keep
the cross-hair on the plane,
to calculate the lead.
And one of the reasons I show
you this is that one of the
real themes that runs through
the work that gets done at MIT
is not just the microwave
physics itself, but the user
interfaces for a lot
of these things.
And building on that work that
we talked about with the
differential analyzer, how you
actually kind of match these
systems to human performance
is really one of the big
themes in the research.
And that sort of leads us
obviously up through Weiner
and cybernetics.
This is one of the divisions of
the NDRC, which was devoted
to fire control, which is that's
the same issue about
how do you aim these different
kinds of guns?
And I give you this list because
I want to show you the
combination of people who were
here and the representatives
from both industry and the
government and then also in
the world of computing.
So just to give you
a couple examples.
This guy here is Warren Weaver,
who is one of the
senior people at the Rockefeller
Foundation, who
funds Bush's differential
analyzer.
Also is the guy who invented the
term "molecular biology."
And so he comes from the kind
of pre-World War II private
foundation world of
science funding.
This is Preston Bassett, who is
the president of the Sperry
Gyroscope Company, which makes
a lot of these kinds of
control systems.
Harold Hazen, who is a student
of Bush, who writes the first
paper on the theory of
servomechanisms in 1934 and
becomes dean of engineering
at MIT.
This guy here is
George Stibitz.
He invented the word "digital"
and built all kinds of control
computers out of telephone
relays during the war.
This guy is Ivan Getting.
And I'll talk about him
in a little bit.
He did a lot of the early
work on radar.
And later on, was really
the father of the GPS
constellation, that we now
use to navigate our cars.
Karl Wildes, also a electrical
engineering
professor here at MIT.
George Philbrick, who really
kind of invented the analog
computer, electrical
analog computer.
And we'll talk a little bit more
about that in a minute.
So you have all these people
sort of coming together on
this problem.
None of them had ever thought
about this problem before in
their entire careers.
Which was sort of a benefit,
right, because the Navy
figured they knew how to do it
and all these guys just sort
of came in and did it
in a different way,
with some fresh ideas.
This is an electronic,
analog electronic
computer that they built.
You see these two guys here
looking through these sites.
The actual electronics for
the computer is here.
And they follow an airplane
with these optical sites.
And then it actually has giant
servos on the gun that
actually point the gun to aim
it in the right place
and then fire it.
So it's the beginning
of a kind of
integrated control system.
And anybody here ever hear the
term "operational amplifier"
or use an operational
amplifier?
It's one of the basic building
blocks of modern electronics.
It's sort of the basic
feedback loop.
Any of you take, what is it
6002, I think they probably do
op amps in that course.
The first op amps are invented
to go into this device.
And the whole idea of a feedback
amplifier being used
to do addition and subtraction
and multiplication and
division and integration and
differentiation, all comes out
of this device, from again, from
the telephone company.
Again, we read about Wiener.
Weiner is a sort of mathematical
adviser to all
these guys.
The book that I assigned the
intro for you is from 1948,
Cybernetics.
But as he talks about in there,
really kind of the
genesis of it was him thinking
about anti-aircraft fire
control during the
Second World War.
And of course, now we have the
idea of cyberspace and cyber
this, and my Sony Cyber-shot,
and all this kind of stuff.
The basic ideas of a lot of
this came from people like
Norbert Wiener, working
out not only the basic
mathematics--
in fact, you can see them
on the board here.
If you read the rest of that
book of Cybernetics, which is
a lot of mathematics, a lot of
it is the basic equations for
what today you call signal
processing or digital signal
processing.
It wasn't digital
when he did it.
But the whole idea of
correlation and convolution
and different kinds of
filters and stuff
is came out of there.
Yup?
AUDIENCE: So actually I got
curious and went onto
Wikipedia and looked them up.
Those equations are actually on
Wikipedia under an article
called the "Weiner filter."
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The Weiner filter is a sort of
classic optimal filter that is
a predecessor to the common
filter, which is something
that people use all
the time today in
design and control systems.
There's Building 20, which is
the actual radiation lab.
Let's see if we can orient
ourselves to it.
Well, I'll let you see
if you can do it.
What are you seeing there?
AUDIENCE: Is that
Vassar Street?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This is Vassar Street here.
AUDIENCE: Oh, wow.
It's really big.
PROFESSOR: It's big.
It was built in about
four months.
It lasted about 40 years,
probably longer, 45 years.
It was basically built like
an army barracks.
What's this right here?
I think that's us.
AUDIENCE: That's where
we are now.
PROFESSOR: Where we
are right now.
In fact, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Almost exactly.
PROFESSOR: What's this?
AUDIENCE: Swimming pool.
PROFESSOR: That's the alumni
pool, which is right out the
window, which was already
built then.
Everything that happened
is built around that.
And so here is the--
I'm not sure which
building that is.
That looks like one of the
original main group buildings.
So there's the Rad Lab.
You can see this huge
loading dock.
Lots of stuff going
in and going out.
These different kind
of fingers.
And all these wacky radar
antennas up on the roof for
experimental testing.
Does nobody know what was it--
it's still there today--
the Christian
Science church downtown?
If you go like to Boston
Symphony Hall, there's a big
plaza and there's a dome.
Which before Boston was built
up, that was one of the
prominent features of
the Boston skyline.
That was the first microwave
radar target in history, from
a building at MIT, fired over
and reflected off that dome.
This is just an image
of the various labs.
There's many of these different
labs in the Rad Lab.
And it's considered a kind of
prototype of what a modern R&D
lab could be set up like.
You can see here,
it's divided up.
There's a receiver lab, an
indicator antenna lab, a
shielded room, a darkroom.
If you know the history
of physics,
you'll know a lot of--
Lee Dubridge was
the head of it.
I.I. Rabi is a famous
Columbia physicist.
Kenneth Bainbridge I think
was a Nobel Prize winner.
I'm not sure about that.
Pollard later won
the Nobel Prize.
So lots of people, who later
became very, very important,
including people like Paul
Samuelson, the Noble Prize
winning economist here at MIT,
that you might not expect.
So the Rad Lab gets started
around this
device, the cavity magnetron.
Anybody seen something
like this before?
There's two places you
might have seen it.
AUDIENCE: It's on the
poster in Lab 7.
PROFESSOR: So three.
It is on the poster in Lab 7.
Very good.
I forgot about that one.
Where else?
AUDIENCE: The museum.
PROFESSOR: So there's
one in the museum.
One other place you might have
seen it, knowing what MIT
students might be like.
If you ever take apart a
microwave oven, you'll see one
of these things inside there.
In fact, that's kind
of the only place
you'll still find them.
So this device is only
about this big.
If you go to the museum,
you'll see it.
It's one of the 150 objects.
And radar had been invented
in the early '30s really.
But it was pretty
long-wave radar.
I may have a picture of it.
Yeah.
So this is pre-World
War II radar.
This is built by Western
Electric, which is
part of Bell Labs.
And there's a couple of key
things to notice about it.
What do you notice about it?
It's really big.
Why is it big?
AUDIENCE: With long waves.
AUDIENCE: It's using relatively
long wavelengths,
in the sort of hundreds of
megahertz wavelengths.
You can see the antenna
and all the wires
for it on the left.
And this is pretty much
state of the art when
the Rad Lab is founded.
And more or less, this
is an American radar.
But the British have a version
of this that they used during
the Battle of Britain, they call
it Chain Home, that is
able to detect attacking
aircraft.
And it does actually
work in fact.
In fact, the Pear Harbor attack
was detected by one of
these right radars, as SCR-268
268, before it happened, a
couple hours before
it happened.
But nobody really had any
faith in the technology.
And it was new.
And people didn't really
understand it.
And it was just a bunch of
blips on the screen.
And the warning that the radar
station issued, was ignored.
Tells you something about any
technology needs to develop
its own credibility and to have
people believe in it.
After that, they tended to
believe in it, once it--
But it's a very big radar.
It's pretty unwieldy.
You can see, it probably didn't
work very well in the
rain, because the guys are all
standing there outside,
exposed, and the electronics
are fairly exposed.
He's just looking into an
oscilloscope right there.
That's a pre-World War
II oscilloscope.
It's the size of a Volkswagen
practically.
And you see he's looking in
through just a darkened hood.
And the British, the problem
was that for higher
frequencies, it was that very
hard to generate enough power,
at what they call microwave
frequencies, which is sort of
centimeters and below, in the
kind of high hundreds of
megahertz up to several
gigahertz range.
And the British come
up with this thing
called a cavity magnetron.
There it is.
And again, it's not a
big device at all.
But I'll show you the shape
of it in a little bit.
It's got a central hole and
there's little resonators all
around it, a very characteristic
shape of what's
inside there.
You put that in a magnetic field
and pump a very high
voltage into it and it generates
really large, very
high-power microwaves.
And this has all kinds
of advantages.
But the key one is that it's
just small and the antennas
are small and it allows you to
do all kinds of different
things with it.
But it implies a whole new
kind of electronics.
For example, you may be familiar
with this, but
microwaves at high powers
don't really like to go
through wires.
They need to go through pipes.
What are those pipes called?
Anybody know?
AUDIENCE: Wave guides.
PROFESSOR: They're called
wave guides, right.
So you have to invent
a whole new kind
of wiring or plumbing.
You literally plumb this
kind of stuff through.
And all that stuff
didn't exist.
But what the British did
was they built this.
They figured out
that it worked.
And in September of 1940, they
were being bombed to
smithereens by the Nazis
on a regular basis.
They were barely surviving
the war effort.
And they didn't have a big
electronics industry.
So it wasn't easy for them to
contemplate how to manufacture
this thing in large numbers.
So one scientist, his name was
Sir Henry Tizard, he came over
to the US on an ocean liner,
exposed to Nazi submarines.
And he brought one of these.
Actually, I think he brought
three of them in a trunk that
he kept under his bed
on the ocean liner.
It was probably the most secret
military technology of
the war at the time.
And he just brought it on this
civilian liner, sort of
wrapped up in his socks
and underwear.
That's exaggeration.
I think he had a special
box for it.
And he brought them.
And he brought them to the
government and said, we have
this thing.
And we want you to have it.
And we want the Americans
to figure it out.
They actually intended for Bell
Labs to deal with it.
And they brought it to the NDRC
and Bush sort of said,
well, we'll bring
this up to MIT.
And they founded
a lab about it.
That's what happens in
October of 1940.
And that's when the Radiation
Lab is founded.
And it's interesting, because
Rabi is said to
have taken it out.
And people said to him, he said
well, how does this thing
actually work?
And they said well,
that's easy.
It works just like a whistle.
It's like an electronic whistle,
because you put power
into it and it generates
a resonance.
And then Rabi looks up at it and
he says, OK, well tell me
how a whistle works?
And nobody at the time could
really explain to him how a
whistle worked.
But that's not a bad way to
think about what the cavity
magnetron does.
AUDIENCE: So are you implying
that the establishment of the
Rad Lab here really rested on
the proposition that it's not
what you know, but you know?
PROFESSOR: To some degree.
And actually it should be said
that of the three, I can't
remember the exact number that
came over, one of them
went to Bell Labs.
And they also did a lot of work
in microwave radar during
the war, but there was work
enough to do for everybody.
So this is an image--
I actually have a blown-up
picture of this on the wall in
my office, because one of the
great things about the Rad Lab
is that photography was kind
of newly cheap at the time.
And they documented a lot of
the research with thousands
and thousands of photographs.
And years ago, I was working
through some of those
photographs at the MIT Museum
and I said to Debbie Douglas,
there's great pictures of daily
life at MIT during World
War II in the Rad Lab things,
that are not the sort of PR
photos you usually see
about the Rad Lab.
And then she took a bunch of
those photos, and they're all
beautiful four by five
negatives, and blew them up
and did a little art
show of them.
And this is one which
I really like.
And I'll turn the lights
off, if I can.
Just generally you can
see them better.
That do anything?
Nope.
OK.
Just to look at them a little
bit about life at MIT during
the war, which Debbie's chapter
does a nice job of
describing.
What can you observe
from this image?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: The really, really
high waist lines.
PROFESSOR: OK, high
waist lines.
AUDIENCE: God, who wears there
pants up that high?
AUDIENCE: Both women.
PROFESSOR: There are
women there.
A lot of women worked at the
Rad Lab, very, very mixed
gender environment.
AUDIENCE: That would be sort of
the scientific version of
Rosie the Riveter
in that sense.
Lots of women go into the
workforce doing this--
AUDIENCE: They were going to
work as scientists or as other
technicians.
PROFESSOR: Mostly as
technicians and
administrators.
Actually, I'm not even aware of
one that worked as a senior
scientist or even an engineer.
What else?
AUDIENCE: The facilities
are not like--
I can see piping.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's pretty much the
inside of Building 20.
That's what it looked like.
It was literally built
in a few weeks.
What else?
This one just captures this, I
think the sort of sense of the
pace that the place
must have had.
You have a sense, everybody's
busy.
They're walking somewhere
quickly.
They're moving things around.
There's equipment coming
across the hall.
That is a microwave
radar antenna.
That's a pretty radical
departure from the previous
slide I showed you of what a
radar antenna looked like.
That you can imagine putting
on board an airplane.
And there's also the two
cigarettes there.
These guys all sort of
identically dressed.
You get the sense it's a place
where just things are moving
fast, sort of like MIT today.
It wouldn't be out of place that
scene, in the Infinite
Corridor between
classes today.
Here is another image, a much
more formal one obviously, of
the steering committee
of the Rad Lab.
You see people in here, like I
mentioned Ivan Getting, who is
here, who later went on, as I
mentioned, to sort of spun the
GPS project.
Anybody know who that
is right there?
That's Jerry Weisner, who
later became President
Kennedy's science adviser
and president of MIT.
I think this is Lee Dubridge,
who's the head of it.
But again, a pretty informal
environment.
Part of the weekly meeting,
another one.
This may be the first time here,
and Debbie had mentioned
in her article and a bunch you
mentioned in your response
papers, the secrecy
that was going on.
Now, these days if any of have
ever worked in even a mild
corporate lab, you probably
have to wear a
badge all the time.
This was probably the first
time people had to
wear badges at MIT.
And this is what a badge
looked like.
It was a little button.
It had your picture on it,
your employee number, and
allowed you to get into certain
places and not into
other places.
Again, it was called
the Radiation
Laboratory for a reason.
What was the reason?
AUDIENCE: Disguise.
PROFESSOR: To fool people into
thinking it might be a nuclear
physics laboratory.
It was about radiation.
But it was not called the
radar-- well, the word "radar"
wasn't even well recognized
anyway at that point.
But it tried to disguise it.
Again, as we mentioned,
lots of women
working in these labs.
Probably a pretty different
work environment than what
people were used to.
Even though we've talked about
women at MIT before, not in
these kind of numbers and
this much involved in
the technical work.
This is just a page out of the
yearbook that the Rad Lab
produced, showing all
the different kinds
of things they did.
It didn't come out that well
in the slide here.
Another image, I love their
images of this sort of
electronic experimentation
stuff.
It has s sort of thrown
together sense of the
director's chair,
an oscilloscope.
What I find interesting is that
a lot of the connectors
on all these machines are still
connectors you might use
today, like a BMC connector.
You still see those
everywhere.
And this is what it took to get
this stuff up and running.
More pictures of the labs, in
this case without people.
So this is probably the radar
that was shown before in that
hallway photo and is one of the
more famous products of
the Rad Lab.
It was called H2X.
And what H2X did was
it allowed, if
you were in a bomber--
the US and the British were
bombing Germany on a regular
basis during most of the war--
but they had this famous Norden
bombsight, which would
allow you to sight bombs.
What was the problem
with the Norden
bombsight, anybody know?
If it was cloudy, you
couldn't use it.
And if anybody's ever been to
Germany or northern Europe,
during eight months of the
year it's pretty cloudy.
And what this is, is
a microwave radar.
Again, it's not just an
advantage that the antenna is
small, but the wavelengths
are small enough.
You can see things that are very
small, so you can make
out a lot of detail.
But you could actually fly over
in cloud cover and map
out a river and a city
and all this stuff.
And it allowed them to bomb with
radar, either at night or
in bad weather.
It had a huge impact.
The other thing about H2X,
it was very important.
It's worth keeping in mind about
radar, because you see
this with other weapons
projects.
Almost any weapons project that
got made during the war,
that actually was designed to
blow something up, it was
very, very hard for it to have
impact in the war because for
one thing, to go from a
prototype in October of 1940
through development and testing
and production pretty
much took the whole war.
So there was basically one full
product development cycle.
If you look at like the great
airplanes of the Second World
War, the B29, the B17, these
were all finished by the time
the war started and it still
took them years to get into
production.
Whereas, if you had, a radar,
you could basically make one
of them, send it out in the
field in one of a bombing raid
of 1,000 bombers and
make a difference.
So radar had this leveraging
effect, where you could use
very, very small numbers
of them and
still have a big impact.
Which any kind of gun, if you
didn't make a gun in numbers
of the tens of thousands, it
was not going to have any
impact on the war.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: How long between the
development of that product
would it be then on plane?
PROFESSOR: In the case of the
radiation lab, it would be
weeks or months.
AUDIENCE: Weeks or months.
PROFESSOR: And actually, no
small number of MIT engineers
went in the field,
made them work,
went on bombing missions.
A few of them were killed,
literally taking these things
in the field.
Think about it any lab prototype
you've ever made, it
may be a little rickety in terms
of its robustness for
being in the field.
It takes a lot of engineering to
go from there to a package
that some soldier is going
to take out of a box.
They didn't always wait
for that time.
And they did send people
directly from the Rad Lab into
the field, to train the troops
and help them get up to speed.
In fact, Karl Compton, the
president of MIT, was not--
in a sense, Bush, before then,
he was junior to Compton.
He goes in and becomes head of
the NDRC and is senior to him.
Compton became head of what was
called the Office of Field
Service, where they
did exactly that.
They took all these things out
and they helped people
understand how to use them.
There's a B17 at Hanscom
Field, right out in the
suburbs here, where the
Rad Lab had a station.
And they would do a lot of
testing and a lot of different
experimentation and flight
tests and stuff,
also at Logan Airport.
Here's a H2X installation inside
a B17, to allow the
radar operator to look
through the sight.
And again, think about
what a different kind
of radar this is.
The one I showed you from
before, the prewar radar,
they're basically soldiers on
the battlefield, these guys.
They're wearing helmets and
they're very exposed.
Here, not only are you in a
high-altitude bomber, but the
guy has a desk.
It's much more like bringing a
laboratory out into the war
time field.
And there's a lot of interesting
stuff about
thinking about radar as a way
to isolate yourself from the
battlefield and manipulate
things on screens.
One of the technicians who
worked on these radars was a
guy named--
well, what's the name--
Douglas Engelbart.
Anybody know what he did?
He invented the mouse.
And he'll tell you, during the
war I worked on radar.
And I started to deal with like
moving things around as
blips on screens using things
to turn things around.
And after the war, when I
started to work at Stanford
and user interface stuff, he
was not an MIT guy, some of
the ideas for interactive
computing really came out of
this idea of looking
at a screen.
This is a famous image,
one of the Rad Lab's
sort of iconic images.
Anybody know what it is?
AUDIENCE: It's Cape Cod.
PROFESSOR: It's Cape
Cod, right.
So this here is just a
map showing you where
the airplane was.
And there's a radar on there.
The antenna spins around.
And this is one of the first H2X
images, plotting out the
contours of the land there.
And so you'll see this appear in
another second in something
I'll show you.
But this gives you the sense of,
very, very different from
blips on a screen.
You're really able to sort
of map where you.
A whole other level of detail
and in the military setting,
that was very, very important.
Here's even a higher
resolution one.
This is an image from an
airplane, looking at another
airplane nearby.
And just to get a sense for
that resolution, too.
You know, crude by today's
standards in some sense of
digital radars and stuff, but
pretty fancy for that day.
And anybody know what this
is, dead giveaway?
This is the northern coast
of France on D-Day.
And here is the radar image of
the fleet that's going to be
the invasion force, taken
from an airplane.
And you can see 6 June, 7:00
o'clock in the morning, taken
from a plane that was above.
This is Western England.
Another interesting
radar is this one.
It's a SCR-584.
It was actually the first
tracking radar.
And so in the history of control
theory and feedback
control, it was the first radar
that could actually move
its antenna based on
where it's target
was and follow something.
And they actually used these to
track the buzz bombs that
came across to England
later in the war
and shoot them down.
It became also sort of an iconic
radar, because this
tracking head, it's
interesting,
it was made by Chrysler.
And a lot of the gearing
in it was taken
out of Chrysler trucks.
And it has these servos on it.
It was a very, very good, very
high precision tracking head.
You see it in post-war
photographs for tracking
rockets and doing sort
of early NASA work.
And you'll still see
these radar mounts.
If you ever watch like storm
trackers or anything, and
their people who track tornadoes
and stuff, they
actually use army surplus
radar mounts like this.
But this radar also, sort of
serves the same purpose as the
268 that I showed you before.
but again, they bring the
operators inside the trailer,
inside this sort of
closed laboratory.
And it's very much thinking
of the battlefield and the
electronic battlefield of
bringing all these blips into
a laboratory setting.
And again, but the ultimate
culmination of that are these
big command and control centers
you see during the
Cold War, you see during the
space program, but it's just
the beginning of that.
That's the inside of a CR-584,
where they can plot
things on the map.
Also, this was one
of the early air
traffic control radars.
It was precise enough that they
could tell the pilots
where they were and guide them
by radio, say come up, come
down, come up and down, and land
them in very, very rough
weather conditions.
So I think this is
the last image.
This is actually an
important image.
At the end of the war, anybody
know what happened to the
Radiation Lab?
Is it here today?
Any of you students
in the Rad Lab?
Nope.
AUDIENCE: I think part
of it became the RLE.
PROFESSOR: Part of it
did become the RLE.
And the rest of it?
It just closed down one day.
And went from 1945 to 1946, it
shut down by a factor of 95%,
and then all together in 1947.
Which is a very interesting
thing.
It would be very hard to
do in today's world.
Remember from the Hunter Dupree
article about Bush, one
of the reasons he was able to
grow this thing so quickly and
so rapidly was that he always
promised it would only last
until the war was over.
And then it ended and he
kept true to his word.
And the OSRD closed down.
The NDRC closed down.
And the Rad Lab just
closed down.
Which by the way, was not a
bad way to influence the
American electronics industry.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Probably there were
lots of people who knew about
electronics looking for work.
PROFESSOR: It dispersed
all that knowledge
out into the world.
And a lot of those people, many
of them went to work on
radar, but a lot of them went
to work on television.
The early American television
industry was largely composed
of Rad Lab graduates,
who knew a lot about
high frequency control.
Also a lot of the early vacuum
but computers, Eckert and
Mauchly, who built ENIAC at
University of Pennsylvania--
I know I'm going to
forget which one--
I think it was Mauchly, came
from the Rad Lab, where he
learned about how to make vacuum
tubes do high-speed
pulse electronics, which by the
way is essentially digital
electronics.
So these people all dispersed
into the world.
The RLE, which still does exist
today, became the kind
of intellectual core, people
like Wiesner and Wiener, a
bunch of other people--
I'll talk about that in the
next two weeks, I think.
And otherwise, the Radiation
Lab closed down.
But before they did, I meant
to bring one of these, they
published everything they did in
a big series of textbooks.
I think it's like
28 textbooks.
And they just published it out
to the world by McGraw Hill,
not secret, not classified,
none of that.
And some of the first books in
servomechanisms were there,
antenna design, systems
engineering.
The first book ever in systems
engineering came
out of the Rad Lab.
It was called Radar System
Engineering.
And they have this
characteristic.
You can still get them.
But the original ones
had this sort of
burgundy cover with it.
And this was the logo they
had on the front.
So what is that logo?
It's the Cape Cod image.
Anybody know what this is?
AUDIENCE: That's the cavity.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's the shape inside
the cavity magnetron.
It's sort of their logo.
And if you cut a cavity
magnetron open, that's what
you'd see, is those little
circles that are all the
different resonate cavities,
where I believe the wavelength
of the radar is the
circumference of that cavity.
I meant to bring--
I have a few of the volumes.
I don't have the whole set.
You can buy the whole
set on eBay.
It's not hard to fine.
Because most people think
of it as obsolete.
But you can find them in
the libraries, as well.
And it's a very famous
textbook series.
And for most people who studied
electronics in the
postwar period, they learned a
lot of it from this Radiation
Lab series of textbooks.
So we were talking about secrecy
and the effects of
secrecy on campus.
This is a sort of anti-secrecy
effect, that it really just
had the goal of--
yes, the Russians got it.
Yes.
Maybe some of our enemies
learned something from it.
But that was probably way less
proportional than what our own
people learn about it and
what came out of it.
I think that's my last slide.
AUDIENCE: That was the origins
of OpenCourseWare?
PROFESSOR: The origins
of OpenCourseWare,
in some way, yeah.
I mean I think that was the
same kind of spirit.
And that's one of the reasons
that people like Bush felt
that this stuff belong
in universities.
Because if it was in the Navy
lab or in an Army lab, it
would go behind closed
doors and stay there
forever pretty much.
It's very hard to get stuff
published out of there.
I'll just look at in
the numbers I have
here, if any of them--
So then going on from there,
I mean the Research Lab of
Electronics is a really
interesting
topic in and of itself.
And they get into acoustics
in a big way.
People like, as we mentioned,
Jerry Wiesner is there.
Weiner is there.
People like Amar Bose
come out of there.
And the Bose Corporation, who
may make your headphones or
your speakers, is a spin-off
from the RLE.
Even people like Noam Chomsky
kind of get their start in
that world.
And there are a lot of
intellectual ties to, this is
a little bit of a diversion, but
if you think about some of
the early work that goes on in
linguistics here that Chomsky
does, it has very much the
same kind of systems
engineering approach to it,
about thinking about grammar
and language, along the lines
of people are thinking about
these different kinds of systems
and systems ideas.
That was the Lily Kay piece that
Will mentioned, that we
cut off the syllabus
for this year.
The same thing in biology,
people thinking about
information and communication
in these more and
more unified ways.
So what's remarkable about the
war is that this effort ended
at the end of the Second World
War, but it had all of these
kind of fingers that lasted.
We'll talk next week about
Whirlwind and digital
computing and aerospace
and stuff on campus.
But it's not a coincidence the
way that Cybernetics is
published in 1948, Claude
Shannon's information theory
is published in 1948.
Also interestingly, I think it's
1948, Kurt Vonnegut first
novel, Player Piano, is
published in 1948.
Has anybody read that book?
It's a really interesting
book.
And the lead character in it,
I believe is named Norbert.
Am I right about that?
It's been a while.
It's got a very clear allusion
to Norbert Wiener.
It's all about the implications
of cybernetics in
factories and other
kinds of settings.
And there is this intellectual
thread that runs through a lot
of this work about this link
between systems, and human
machine interfaces, and
communication, and feedback
control, and computing,
that you can carry
that through at MIT.
And we'll talk later
about Project MAC,
which is the 1960s.
20 years later, people are
still thinking about
interactive computing in
very similar ways.
I mentioned Doug Engelbart, who
was not an MIT guy, but
very much is very clear in his
memoirs, that he started
thinking about these issues when
he was interacting with
the radar during the war.
And then it's only out of this
that you really get the
beginnings of digital computing
and I think, and
I'll talk about this next time,
a very particularly MIT
take on those technologies
that's not so much focused on
the kind of basic mathematics
of them, but really thinking
of these computers as embedded
in control systems, much in
the way that all these different
radars were embedded
in control systems.
So that's where you can sort of
see that the way that MIT
is organized, the way that the
federal government is funding
science and technology, and
the politics of Washington
around it, and the actual
content of what kind of work
people are doing, and what sort
of ideas they're doing,
are all really very much
connected in this story about
World War II.
It's hard to overemphasize how
much profound influence on the
world that we live in, even just
even just the local world
here, came out of this really
just five-year, seven-year
period at MIT.
We also looked at "Science,
The Endless Frontier." And
that was where Truman came to
Bush at the end of the war,
pretty much at the end of the
war, because Truman isn't even
president until right before the
war ends, and says, what
are we going to do in
this in the future?
How are we going to
take this forward?
And Bush writes this report,
whereas somebody commented in
the response for today, it's
really very forward thinking
where he says, OK, we're
done with war.
That's important.
But let's really think about
doing this in a context that's
really going to help our people,
and that's medicine
and biomed and other sorts of
civilian applications to it.
And that report to this day,
I mean that's sort of--
has anybody read that before the
class or heard about it?
It's sort of basic required
reading, if you have a career
in science in the US.
It really is considered the
template for how the NIH and
the NSF and a lot of other
federal agencies work.
Interestingly, it's not so much
the continuation of the
OSRD model.
The OSRD model kind
of dies in 1945.
If anything, it's carried on
by the Office of Naval
Research, which is a very small
office, during the five
years after the war.
And then late in the '50s, I
think it's picked up again
when DARPA is formed in
1958, also with a
very big MIT input.
We'll talk about
that next time.
But if you want to look at the
modern heir to the OSRD, it's
not the National Science
Foundation.
The National Science Foundation
works by peer review.
It has a charge to not only fund
the best science, but to
do education and to sort of
spread its resources out,
throughout the country in
a kind of even way.
Whereas DARPA is much more
based on the model of the
OSRD, intentionally or
unintentionally.
You have very strong program
managers, who can sort of
shape the fields the
way they see fit.
It's within the military, but
it doesn't belong to the Air
Force or the Army or the Navy.
And it has does its
own sort of thing.
And it's sort of set apart,
very much in the same way.
But that's--
AUDIENCE: It's run academics.
PROFESSOR: --another story.
It's run by academics, yeah.
And the first director was
Jack Ruina, who was a
colleague of ours here.
We'll talk about
that next time.
That's a post-Sputnik thing.
That's the next big thing
that happened.